Olá aqui é o gerenciamento de
stakeholders level VPS alto nível
e não é só sobre falar só sobre
resultado tá você precisa levar as
descobertas que você tem sobre o cliente
então sobre usuários sobre os insights
os dados mas você precisa levar isso de
uma forma que você conta história Rápido
Você prende a atenção do seu contexto
rápido então beleza isso daqui atingir o
resultado tal fez o epilift de tanto
nessa métrica que impacta na receita em
Y Então você conecta o Pinel o resultado
de receita né com a métrica de produto
Mas você também precisa trazer outras
coisas Olha a gente tá olhando aqui nas
entrevistas que a gente fez são esses
pontos foram os pontos que saíram de
atenção nas últimas entrevistas que a
gente fez com o usuário isso aqui
conversa com esses dados que a gente tá
olhando com não sei que te concorrente
por isso queria também a segurança para
as pessoas que que você tá olhando para
as coisas que você precisa olhar então
quando fala com celular quando fala
sobre a alce level não quer saber meu
trabalho VP nunca no meu trabalho não
ele quer e muito
só que a gente também precisa saber
e levar essa informação rápida com cinza
e tipo o quê que vai prender a atenção
então
levem essa informação vá além de mostrar
o resultado mostro também as coisas que
vocês estão descobrindo porque isso
ajuda se level pensar Ah então tá bom
está descobrindo Isso é um problema
curso como é que eu posso ajudar a
resolver esse problema de outras formas
fora o produto